[Music]  the European economy has enjoyed six  consecutive years of growth and is set  to continue expanding this year and next  year the number of people in employment  is at record high unemployment continues  to fall and incomes are rising these are  good news investment also continues to  grow the budget deficit for the euro  area as a whole is forecast to remain  below 1% of GDP and we expect public  debt to keep on declining inflation is  expected to remain low in spite of  rising wages the more moderate expansion  forecast for this year we know that is  are largely due to weaker growth in  other parts of the world and temporary  setbacks in some sectors of the economy  uncertainty also remains high and there  is the risk of new roadblocks to trade  overall the European economy is proving  resilient with the right policies we can  ensure that it remains